we're asked to factor 4y squared plus 4y
minus 15. and whenever you have an
expression like this where you have a
non-one coefficient on the y squared or
on the second degree term it could have
been an x squared the best way to do
this is by grouping and to factor by
grouping we need to look for two numbers
whose product is equal to 4 times
negative 15. so we're looking for two
numbers whose product let's call those a
and b is going to be equal to 4 times
negative 15. 4 times negative fifteen or
negative sixty and the sum of those two
numbers a plus b
needs to be equal to this four right
there
needs to be equal to four so let's think
let's think about all the factors of
negative 60 or 60 and we're looking for
ones that are essentially four apart
because the numbers are going to be of
different signs because their product is
negative so when you take two numbers of
different signs and you sum them you
kind of view it as the difference of
their absolute values if that confuses
you don't worry about it but this tells
you that the numbers since they're going
to be of different size their absolute
values are going to be roughly 4 apart
so we could try out things like 5 and 12
5 and negative 12 because one has to be
negative if you add these two you get
negative seven if you did negative five
and twelve you'd get positive seven
those are still too far apart what if we
tried
what if we tried
six and negative ten then you get a
negative four if you added these two we
want a positive 4. so let's do negative
6 and 10. negative 6 plus 10 is positive
4. so those will be our two numbers
negative 6 and positive 10.
now what we want to do is we want to
break up this middle term here the whole
point of figuring out the negative 6 and
the 10 is to break up the 4y into a
negative 6y and a 10y so let's do that
so this 4y can be rewritten as negative
6y
plus
10y right because if you add those you
get 4y and then the other sides of it
you have your 4y squared
4y squared and then you have your minus
15. all i did is expand this into these
two numbers
as being the coefficients on the y if
you add these you get the 4y again now
this is where the grouping comes in you
group the terms so let's see this
let me do it in a different color
so if i take these two guys
what can i factor out of those two guys
well there's a common factor it looks
like there's a common factor of 2y so if
we factor out 2y we get 2y
times 4y squared divided by 2y is 2y
and then negative 6y divided by 2y is
negative 3
negative 3. so that gets fact this group
gets factored into 2y times 2y minus 3.
now let's look at this other group right
here this was a whole point about
breaking it up like this and in other
videos i've explained why this works now
here the the greatest common factor is a
5. so we can factor out a 5. so this is
equal to plus
5 times 10y divided by 5 is 2y
negative 15 divided by 5 is 3.
and so we have
2i times 2y minus 3 plus 5 times 2y
minus 3. so now you have two terms so
now you have two terms and 2y minus 3 is
a common factor to both so let's factor
out a 2i minus 3. so this is equal to
2y minus 3
times 2y
times that 2i
plus
plus
that 5
plus that 5. there's no magic happening
here all i did is undistribute the 2y
minus 3. i factored it out of both of
these guys and took it out of the
parentheses if i distribute it in you'd
get back to this expression but we're
done we factored it we factored into two
binomial expressions 4y squared plus 4y
minus 15 is 2y minus 3 times 2y
plus 5.